[Musique]
il y a encore trois ans c'était une
vallée coupée du monde moderne à 700 km
de la capitale dans les contreforts de
l'Himalaya la ville de Kellogg est
depuis peu relié au réseau Internet de
quoi changer la vie de ces 1200
habitants c'est le cas d'hadjekuma un
étudiant en informatique pour toutes ces
démarches administratives ils seront
régulièrement dans ce cybercafé le seul
à disposer d'un haut débit en ville
sur le site des impôts dites à votre
comptable que la déclaration est presque
prête et demandez-lui d'enclencher la
procédure de vérification aussi
simple avant l'ouverture de ce lieu pour
toutes ces démarches nous devions
quitter notre village pour nous rendre
dans la première grande ville du
district qui se trouve à 150 km d'ici
cela prenait neuf à 10 heures de route
[Musique]
de passeport permis de conduire ou
encore déclaration d'impôts plus besoin
de se déplacer des centres comme
celui-ci il en existe quatre 160 000 à
travers le pays il fait partie du
programme digital India une initiative
du gouvernement indien visant notamment
à désenclaver les zones les plus
reculées du pays
petit à petit Internet se déploie aussi
dans les maisons tout comme les antennes
3G 4G qui fleurissent un projet
ambitieux au budget colossal 850
millions d'euros ont été alloués rien
que l'an dernier le but affiché des
autorités que le quotidien des Indiens
bascule dans l'air numérique les
transactions financières au consultation
médicale
nous espérons que d'ici 4 ou 5 ans tous
nos services seront digitalisés les
citoyens n'auront plus besoin de perdre
leur temps à chercher comment faire
telle ou telle démarche tout passera par
internet
48% de la population aurait désormais
accès à Internet soit près de 650
millions d'Indiens internet est devenu
un outil dont se sont emparés des
milliers de citoyens devenus du jour au
lendemain des créateurs de contenu ou
des influenceurs d'après une étude doc
sur des économique en 2024000 chaînes
YouTube indiennes auraient dépassé le
million d'abonnés un chiffre en
constante progression à 300 km de nude
dans l'état rural de l'Ariana est l'un
des premiers à cette relancée dans des
vidéos à destination des fermiers du
pays c'est bon on peut commencer
tu vois il faut voir cette plante
n'hésite pas à faire des gros plans
bonjour les amis parlons d'une plante
qui peut nourrir votre bétail et qui va
réduire drastiquement vos coûts
d'agriculture il a quitté son travail en
ville en 2017 pour lancer sa propre
chaîne qui cumule désormais près de 5
millions d'abonnés
j'ai remarqué avant de me lancer qu'il y
avait pléthore de vidéos de tutoriels
qui parlait d'actualité de comment
remplir ses impôts ou encore
d'automobile en Inde mais il n'y avait
rien sur l'agriculture les fermiers
indiens MC vidéo car on leur donne des
conseils pour mieux être rentable par
exemple et seul internet permet de
réaliser cela grâce à internet ils
peuvent nous regarder nous écouter en
étant dans leur ferme à l'autre bout du
pays
au programme technique agricole
promotion de produits ou encore
rencontre avec d'autres fermiers entre
les contenus sponsorisés et le nombre de
vues Darshan parvient à monétiser ses
vidéos et à multiplié par 3 ses revenus
en gagnant pour tout le monde nos
spectateurs peuvent accéder à des
contenus gratuits en ligne et nous les
réalisateurs de ces vidéos sont payés
par YouTube ou encore Google en fonction
du nombre de vues cela varie tous les
mois bien entendu mais cela peut nous
rapporter entre 1000 et 6000 euros par
mois
mais la révolution numérique a aussi ses
limites en Inde le pays est l'un des
plus touchés par les fausses
informations qui circulent sur les
réseaux sociaux sans compter la censure
qui a explosé depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir en 2014 du BJP le parti
nationaliste hindou du Premier ministre
Narin dramadi depuis 2018 le pays figure
sur le podium du classement des
gouvernements qui coupe délibérément
Internet une situation alarmante décrié
par cette association de défense des
droits et des libertés numériques rien
que ces deux dernières années le
gouvernement indien a bloqué l'accès à
15000 sites et adresses Internet et
c'est toujours fait de manière très
opaque car vous n'avez jamais la
possibilité d'être entendu par le
gouvernement ou une cour de justice pour
contester pour nous recevez aucun
courrier vous expliquant pourquoi vous
avez été victime de censure du jour au
lendemain votre tweet ou votre statut
Facebook ou votre site internet ou
chaîne Youtube sera supprimée et vous ne
saurez jamais pourquoi
une censure qui a un coût rien qu'en
2020 ces coupures internet auraient fait
perdre plus de 3 milliards d'euros à
l'économie selon une étude indépendante